le
[Musique]
les talents mon film avance que tu
balances et si j'ai pas trouvé à titin
iii nancy ii
[Musique]
le monde
[ __ ] voilà ma totale des contreparties
en laponie partent en vacances demain
matin ouais exact voilà donc à très
bientôt pour de nouvelles avec son
bonnet
[Musique]
touché la carotte 1,40 et le gros choux
fleurs
vous
[Musique]
la fin décembre à tous les vents bat na
waie lit clos c'est lequel du coup c'est
celui qui a la casquette de prénom ah
oui les incollables hypnose et l'eau
c'est le maigre est né au lycée le moins
mais la question piège au lycée le
maître celui qui est aussi celui qui est
le cas locales et masseca la casquette
et ses d'autres qui le frère ils ont
trois ans d'écart ils s'adorent depuis
des années ils sont presque comme des
jumeaux
quant à bernis allez bon courage et un
rallye nature est plutôt molle et j'en
fais partie
jusqu'où va le maquillage et les
arrivées jusqu'à ce qu'il en veut moi je
voudrais se tirer
malheureusement les tribunaux l'onu est
très moche par des volcanites avec
nominé à raymond tu me connais ces
dégâts sur leur cv et souvent les yeux
gris qu'il ya un peu de toi
[Musique]